dans l'actualité ce soir barack obama et
le vainqueur des primaires démocrates
aux états unis il a dépassé la nuit
dernière le nombre nécessaire de
délégués c'est la première fois qu'un
candidat noir postule pour la maison
blanche
en france la justice privilégie
l'hypothèse d'une erreur du chauffeur de
car après la collision de haute savoie
les éléments techniques confirmerait
qu'il n'a pas respecté les feux il vient
d'être mise en examen pour homicides et
blessures involontaires et écroué
la colère des pêcheurs se tourner vers
la commission européenne la
manifestation organisée à bruxelles a
dégénéré plus de 70 marins ont été
interpellés deux lettres trois chiffres
et deux lettres les nouvelles plaques
d'immatriculation ont été dévoilés
aujourd'hui le numéro du département
n'est plus indiquée mais une place est
réservée pour un écusson
enfin la victoire de gaël monfils à
roland garros le français révélation du
tournoi se qualifie pour les demi
finales en quatre sets en battant le
numéro cinq mondial david ferrer gaël
monfils qui sera notre invité à la fin
de ce journal
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous ce n'est pas
une surprise mais cela reste une
sensation pour la première fois donc un
homme noir ancien travailleur social
inconnue encore il ya quatre ans portera
les couleurs d'un grand parti à la
présidentielle américaine barack obama
s'est imposé chez les démocrates les
états unis sont extraordinaires a
commenté condoleezza rice pourtant
membre du camp républicain
on va s'y arrêter assez longuement
d'abord le récit de ces dernières heures
avec alain de chalvron et ron diamond à
washington il a eu du mal à prendre la
parole pour fêter son triomphe
ces vingt mille partisans réunis à
minneapolis
ne le laissez pas faire même si tous
attendent et ce magique
ce soir je peux dire devant vous que je
serai le candidat officiel du parti
démocrate à la présidence des états unis
et le présomptif nominé comme on
l'appelle désormais de près c'est une
couronne à la perdante
hillary clinton est entré dans
l'histoire durant cette campagne
c'est un leader qui inspire des millions
d'américains pas de larmes pas d'adieu
déchirantes discours bilan pour hull
arih encore combative encore indécises
ça a été une longue campagne et je ne
prendrai aucune décision ce soir
brawl de sortie pour une candidate qui
semble se poser à elle même la question
que chacun se pose
what tâche que veut il arrive que
veut-elle donc tentative d'explication
ce matin sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision de son directeur de campagne
hillary clinton fera tout ce qu'elle
peut pour faire gagner le parti
démocrate à travers tout le pays
tout est ce à dire qu elles prendraient
même la vice-présidence on en parle de
plus en plus sérieusement même si
beaucoup restent sceptiques f silence
qu'à obama devra faire tester ses plats
parent goûteuse
évidemment ça ne facilitera pas le
fonctionnement de la maison blanche
c'est donc la fin de la partie pour
hillary clinton même si on vient de le
voir elle ne le dit pas encore
explicitement la victoire semblait
pourtant programmée martine
laroche-joubert parce qu'elle joue frire
face au mont rushmore ici sont sculptés
les visages des présidents américains
hillary clinton elle en rêvait
trop tard 20 janvier 2007 elle se lance
dans la course à la maison blanche
certain de l'emporter
une ambition venus de loin fidaa père
républicain elle grandit dans une
famille de classe moyenne intègre la
prestigieuse école de droit de yale
militant contre la guerre du vietnam et
trouve son prince charmant
bill clinton elle croit en son étoile
lille devient gouverneur de l'arkansas
où sont elles vigilant puis président le
rêve tourne au cauchemar le scandale
monica lewinsky
il arrive mulliez serre les dents celle
ci leur fille retient ses parents de
justesse amour ou intérêt bien compris
c'est leur secret il quitte la maison
blanche
ce tour dit larry élue sénatrice de
l'état de new york un tremplin pour cet
ex avocate brillante sûre d'elle trop
2004 un jeune sénateur entre dans la
lumière
hilary tombe sous le charme quatre ans
plus tard il lui fera verser sa première
larmes en public
elle vient de perdre le caucus de l'iowa
j'ai tellement de choses à offrir à ce
pays
je ne veux pas voir ce pays revenir en
arrière
hillary qui a voté la guerre en irak
perçoit mal la menace obama certaines
attaques terra barack obama d'autres
ironisent stater sur la volonté de
changement des démocrates
les anges du ciel ont chanté tout le
monde sera le bien et le monde sera
parfait
le rêve se brise hier soir pour toujours
difficile d'imaginer que hilary ne croit
plus en son destin
barack obama à 46 ans aux états unis les
commentateurs soulignent qu'il est né en
plein combat pour les droits civiques
des noirs ça n'est pas si vieux cette
désignation dit beaucoup de choses sur
l'évolution de l'amérique multiraciale
bernard lebrun valérie lucas barack
hussein obama junior 46 ans n'est pas un
afro américain
mais c'est en afrique que sont ses
racines paternelles là aussi on a fêté
l'incroyable destin du petit fils sous
son porche la grand-mère croise les
doigts pour le 4 novembre
je vais dormir jusqu'au résultat final
dit m il n'aura fallu qu'une génération
pour que le fils d'un émigré venus du
kenya atteigne les sommets
une histoire dont raffolent les
américains né en 1961 sur l'île d'hawaï
d'un père kényan et musulman et d'une
mère américaine et agnostiques barack
obama sera un brillant étudiant boursier
sortie avocats de la prestigieuse
université d'harvard de la foi dans
l'amérique
ce pays a été construit pour que chaque
enfant est une chance dans la vie que
chacun puisse avoir un travail qui lui
permettent de dire bon orateur obama a
pour tout programme une foi inébranlable
dans le rêve américain
à l'aune du titre de son livre l'audace
de l'espoir et l'audace a payé un
candidat métis à gagner obama un
candidat noir en position d'être élu à
la maison blanche c'est un jour
historique pour l'amérique
je sais pas ce qui va se passer après
mais aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un
tournant dans l'histoire de l'amérique
obama vainqueur inattendu des primaires
démocrates
mais qu'adviendra-t-il le 4 novembre
face à john mccain républicain
la société américaine blanche à 75% en
at elle fini avec ses vieux démons
quarante ans après l'assassinât de
martin luther king
pas si sûr je pense que john mccain a
plus que toutes ses chances de gagner le
4 novembre
parce que lorsque les américains vont
dans l'isoloir le racisme existe encore
chez nous ce n'est pas politiquement
correct de le dire mais dans l'isoloir
c'est un endroit très privé on fait ce
qu'on veut barack et michelle obama à la
maison blanche
peut-être mais le chemin sera difficile
bonsoir alain de chalvron vous êtes en
direct à washington beaucoup de
questions ce soir d'abord sur hillary
clinton qui n'a toujours pas reconnu
officiellement sa défaite
on dit qu'elle fait monter les enchères
et de quelle enchères s'agit-il
exactement
oh ben écoutez elle essaye de négocier
au mieux son ralliement à lauriad est
question d'hommes elle veut recaser des
membres de son équipe et des questions
de fond elle veut que des idées à elles
soient reprises mais surtout il ya des
questions d'argent elle ne veut que ses
dettes de campagne on parle de 20 à 30
millions de dollars soit éponger et puis
à l'essentiel son avenir à l est ce
qu'un ticket est envisageable pour
barack obama avec hillary clinton comme
candidate à la vice présidence
oui évidemment quand on se souvient des
passes d'armes entre les deux candidats
pas toujours aimable ça paraît aberrant
mais vous savez c'est un grand classique
de l'histoire américaine séquelles eddie
johnson c'est ronald reagan george bush
en fait barack obama va peser le pour et
contre le pur c'est le ralliement des 18
millions d'électeurs qui ont voté pour
hillary clinton et qui aujourd'hui sont
très déçus certains menacent de changer
de camp le contre est évidemment c'est
l'ombre tutélaire de bill clinton sur la
maison blanche la dernière chose à la 1
100 employés de grands mots est ce qu'on
peut dire que ce jour fera date dans la
vie publique américaine
ah oui je crois qu'on peut utiliser le
mot historique car c'est vrai vous
souvenez ya un an personne n'aurait misé
grand chose sur la victoire de barack
obama au début de la campagne des
primaires en janvier il avait 17 points
de retard sur hillary clinton
alors c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas encore
à la maison blanche mais ne disait on
pas mais les américains sont incapables
de voter pour un noir c'est le moment
n'est pas encore venu
or il ya eu des millions d'hommes blancs
en particulier dans le sud qui ont voté
pour lui et ça rien que ça
c'est un pas gigantesque pour les états
unis merci à la on rappelle que
l'élection présidentielle américaine
aura lieu le 4 novembre prochain à
l'opposera donc barack obama à john
mccain
en france la justice commencent
semble-t-il à y voir plus clair après la
collision à haute savoie l'enquète
s'oriente vers la mise en cause du
chauffeur qui n'auraient pas respecté
les feux il vient d'être mise en examen
et écroué sur place virginie fils
philippe québec
c'est dans un véhicule calfeutrait que
le chauffeur du bus est arrivé au palais
de justice pour y apprendre sa mise en
examen pour homicides et blessures
involontaires par manquement grave à une
obligation de sécurité
une décision qui s'appuie
essentiellement sur neuf témoignages
d'automobilistes et de collégiens de
passagers du car qui affirme que le
chauffeur s'est engagée alors que le feu
était rouge ne dis pas qu'il est d'ores
et déjà coupable c'est pas ça du tout
j'ai estimé moi et ça à partir des
éléments recueillis par la gendarmerie
qu'il y avait suffisamment d'indicés
graves et concordants qui rêvait qui
rendait le vrai son blog ce que nous
venons d'évoquer
à savoir d'avoir l'eau plus d'une
centaine d'auditions a été réalisé ce
qu'il faut à présent recouper et
certifiés de multiples relevés
techniques devraient servir à modéliser
la catastrophe pourrait établir
précisément la vérité là la grande
difficulté pour nous ça sera comme dans
un avion de repositionner chaque enfant
à sa place exacte dans le bus et c'est
là qu'on verra si le témoignage est
plausible ou si c'est le témoignage qui
est le résultat de tout ce qu'ils ont pu
entendre ces derniers jours
une tâche difficile car d'autres
témoignage corrobore la version du
chauffeur qui soutient que le feu
n'était pas rouge pour son avocat sa
part de responsabilité est loin d'être
clairement établie à ce qui était dans
le car aussi qu'ils sont des adultes qui
n'ont pas vu tout à fait la même chose
les cambistes n'ont pas vu exactement la
même chose demain membres les enfants
n'ont pas entendu la même chose au même
moment ce qu une fulgurance de trois
secondes
ce soir le conducteur du car a été placé
en détention provisoire
virginie fichet qu'on retrouve en direct
bonsoir virginie c'est précisément cela
qui retient l'attention ce soir ce
placement en détention quelles sont les
raisons invoquées le procureur explique
que cette mise en détention
et justement à cause de cette multitude
de contradictions dans les déclarations
il a souhaité garder le chauffeur pour
procéder à toute vérification urgente
nous at il dit et éviter toute forme de
pression
une mise en détention et bien que le
chauffeur lui même n'a pas songé une
seule seconde à contester nous expliquer
son avocat pour respect pour les
familles par respect pardon pour les
familles des victimes ces enfants qui
demain seront enterrés et qu'il appelait
lui même ses enfants
merci bien génie la colère des pêcheurs
cette fois et se tourner vers la
commission européenne une manifestation
était organisée à bruxelles
elle a tourné à l'affrontement françois
beaudonnet jean-michel de rose bruxelles
rue de la loi le quartier des affaires
et le quartier européen
il est 13h15 la manifestation des
pêcheurs dia de dégénérer
cinq cents manifestants pour la plupart
français affrontent les forces de
l'ordre belges
ce matin pourtant à leur arrivée les
leaders des pêcheurs tenait un discours
pacifique
on ne va pas pourquoi on est noir tout
sauf le revoir se fera pas de casse
en tout cas jusqu'à ce qu'une délégation
française italienne soit reçue ici dans
les locaux de la commission européenne
et à la sortie
la consigne change du tout au tout
message reçu
dans une ville en état de siège les
pêcheurs se transforme en casseurs
commence alors une course poursuite
entre des petits groupes de manifestants
et les brigades anti-émeutes 15 heures
des policiers en civil interviennent
enfin 74 arrestations musclées dont 73
français
nous avons retrouvé certains d'entre eux
gardent des menottes aux poignets à
l'écart dans un parc eux disent ne rien
avoir saccagé tout cas c'est notre
métier ni aux efforts pour défendre
notre métier passionnant métier son
zippo pendant cinq mois dans un an
y a plus de petit test les échauffourées
auront duré moins de deux heures mais
c'est largement suffisant pour tendre
encore un peu plus les relations entre
les pêcheurs français la commission
européenne et surtout pour ternir
l'image de la france à bruxelles sur le
territoire français c'est une habitude
qui s'installe chaque journée le théâtre
de nouvelles actions des professions
concernées par la hausse des prix du
gazole cette fois c'est à toulouse on va
découvrir quelques images que les
routiers ont bloqué le périphérique ce
matin pendant quatre heures provoquant
de gros embouteillages opération
escargot également autour de l'aéroport
de roissy et plus particulièrement près
de la zone fret les taxis y
participaient également image signée
frédéric capron
que se passe-t-il en slovénie ce la
commission européenne vient il y à
quelques minutes de déclencher le
système d'alerté européen sur les
risques radioactifs après un incident
survenu dans une centrale nucléaire
là-bas bonsoir françois beaudonnet vous
êtes notre correspondant à bruxelles de
quelles informations disposez-vous qui
côté david on a ce soir assez peu
d'informations parce que vous l'avez dit
l'alertent a été déclenchée il y à
quelques minutes seulement alors ce que
l'on sait c'est qu'il s'agit d'une
centrale qui se trouvent dans le sud
ouest de la slovénie ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'il ya une fuite sur le liquide
de réfrigération
une fuite qui n'a pas mené d'explosion
une fuite non plus qui n'est pas sorti à
l'extérieur du bâtiment
cela dit l'incident doit être
suffisamment important puisque la
commission a jugé bon de le communiquer
au grand public ce qui est très rare
cela dit néanmoins david ce qu'on nous
dit ce soir la commission européenne qui
situé à deux pas d'ici
c'est que sur cet incident pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de raison d'être
inquiet merci françois voilà donc fuite
incident dans une centrale nucléaire en
slovénie nous y reviendrons sans doute
d'ici à la fin de ce journal en france
un nouveau village de chalets destiné
aux sans abri sera bientôt construit
près de strasbourg ce sera le sixième
sens en france sur le modèle de ce qui
existe déjà ici en région parisienne ou
encore à caen ces installations sont nés
après le mouvement des enfants de don
quichotte la pénurie de logements dans
les grandes villes n'est pas seulement
la sphère des sans domicile depuis
quelques années on voit des intérimaires
ou des employés bref des personnes
disposant d'un travail dormir dans la
rue travailleurs et sdf c'est le dossier
de cette édition
il est signée jenny briffa marie cros
c'est l'heure des premières rames avec
dans le métro ceux qui travaillent tôt
au bout du quai cinq personnes dorment
pour ne pas être en retard
nicolas ni son réveil
tu travailles tu déménagements attend
pratiquement je suis en intérim
je t'aurais pas suffisamment pour former
depuis deux mois il dort dans le métro
parisien
ils n'arrivent plus à payer les 900
euros d'hôtels hilton 900 euros par mois
900 euros par mois je suis comme à
l'hôtel toulouse avant de partir il
range sa petite maison sur un placard
électrique
il se paye ensuite un café sont pas sans
quelque sorte pour sa salle de bain de
dépannage comme il dit la société
d'intérim qui l'emploie depuis huit ans
ignore sa situation et lui fait tout
pour que personne ne soit au courant
ça alimente le gérant pas grand chose en
fait histoire d'arriver à temps ce sont
tout ça et là c'est la bâche larigot
travailler les gens aimeront non pas
faire la différence j'ai fait quand même
acheter j'étais chez moi j'étais chez
moi je prends du chemin
votre dernière de cinq ans
bonjour j'ai pas le choix je peux faire
aller travailler
mais bon sang entre guillemets un petit
peu qu'elle allait travailler s'ils
protestent réchappa mans ce matin là
nicolas va déménager un diplomate dans
les beaux quartiers
lui qui n'a pas de toit pas ces journées
entières dans les maisons des autres ça
c'est paradoxal c'est tous les jours
jeux de grattage de gens
et eux et moi j'aurais pas rentré que le
départ
pour moi mais bon
la veille il n'a rien mangé pourtant il
va porter des centaines de kilos dans la
journée frédéric lui aussi a dormi
quelques temps dans le métro aujourd'hui
cet intérimaire vie dans un centre
d'hébergement pour sdf
ce jour là il a rendez vous avec le
directeur du centre
cette employée d'hôtel supporte mal sa
situation
mon médecin il m'a donné un réseau mines
a un cachet pour m'aider à me
décompresser les nerfs en tout ça dans
ce centre les deux tiers des
pensionnaires travail dans cette chambre
de 10 mètres carrés ils sont deux l'un
employés au mcdo l'autre agent
d'entretien fait des personnes qui ont
un emploi et qui tourne depuis trois ans
voire quatre ans de foyer en foyer
bon faut dire qu'ils ont un emploi mais
quels emplois intérimaires frédéric
attend chaque jour de savoir s'il
travaillera le lendemain il nous appelle
comme ça vous menez ou venez pas mais
bon moi je me plains pas je il m'appelle
très souvent vous avez l'impression de
sortir du tunnel
oui voilà pas complètement je vois je
peux dire je suis au milieu du tunnel je
voie le jour qu'il arrive
et j'ai quand je serai vraiment leur
avec le sedif plus un appartement
lâcherait odeur de du tunnel le cdi à
temps complet ce devrait être pour
juillet son employeur le lui a promis
18h30 nicolas viennent finir il a gagné
60 euros pour cette journée de travail
tue
fatiguée un petit peu un petit pas en
colère parce que tu dis voilà c'est j'ai
travaillé mais demain ce sera pareil ça
change ça change en rien en commun tout
ne sera pas avec quoi ce soir là il va
retourner dormir sur son quai le visage
tourné vers le mur pour que personne ne
le reconnaissent en ile de france
30% des sdf aurait un emploi économie
encore la direction de bosch confiant la
fermeture de son usine de beauvais on
l'évoquait hier les propositions des 240
salariés de renoncer à l'euro vers
c'était n'y ont rien changé
un succès pour la police dans le sud de
la france quatre tableaux de maîtres
volés au musée des beaux-arts de nice il
ya presque un an ont été retrouvés parmi
ses toiles il y à un monet le commando a
été interpellé aujourd'hui lionel
feirstein christophe laroque une
arrestation en plein jour dans cette rue
50 policiers lourdement armés
les braqueurs du musée nice n'avait
aucune chance ils étaient filés depuis
des semaines un serveur a assisté à
toute la scène pleine de à la police les
gens cagoulés eu un vol de deux tableaux
de le 5 août dernier des hommes masqués
arme au poing pénètre dans le musée des
beaux arts de nice il s'empare de quatre
tableaux de maîtres et pas des moindres
un claude monet falaise près de dieppe
un sisley allée de peupliers de mort est
ainsi que deux brugel valeur de
l'ensemble 20 millions d'euros pour
grégory ce type là en france à ma
connaissance rien at moins de 5
les quatre tableaux ont été récupérés
avec leurs cadres intacte les
malfaiteurs eux sont en garde à vue dans
les locaux de la pj de marseille
c'est en partie grâce à une information
du fbi la police américaine qu'ils ont
été arrêtés les voleurs cherchait depuis
un an à vendre leurs toiles à l'étranger
sans succès deux lettres trois chiffres
et deux lettres les nouvelles plaques
d'immatriculation pour les véhicules ont
été dévoilés aujourd'hui avec un peu
d'avancé pour désamorcer les critiques
vous savez que beaucoup d'élus et
d'automobilistes regrette que le numéro
du département ne soit plus indiqué du
coup une place est réservée pour un
écusson je viens du perray
bernie mériaux la nouvelle plaque
d'immatriculation la voici deux lettres
trois chiffres deux lettres il est vrai
cette combinaison n'a plus aucune
signification
alors face à la colère des amoureux de
leur département
le gouvernement a fait une fleur chacun
pourra quand même rajouter son numéro
ici en bas à droite avec en prime le
logo de la région correspondante
et la grande nouveauté c'est que c'est
l'automobiliste qui choisit un breton
qui habite paris reste très attaché à la
bretagne pourra mettre le 35 et le logo
la bretagne le département sur leurs
plaques
eux ils tiennent assez en tout cas pour
provoquer une manifestation de 169
députés devant l'assemblée nationale
c'était au début du mois de mai la
nouvelle plaque en main nous sommes
allés voir l'un d'entre eux germinal
peiro député de dordogne nouvelles
plaques
c'est la nouvelle plaque
et oui le département sur cette plaque
là si vous voulez vous pouvez leur
ajouter comme ici le verdict est sans
appel avec ou sans nouveau
il préfère garder la plaque actuelle pas
quelque chose qui à mes yeux est est
satisfaisant pourquoi cette
identification ici est parfaitement
lisible quand on se suit en voiture
c'est parfaitement lisible et la fronde
des députés est loin d'être isolé
partout en france des voix
d'automobilistes se sont élevées ici à
lille garder son numéro département si
puisque une question de fierté régionale
je vois pas l'intérêt de changer
question est ce que ça marche ça marche
très bien comme ça je ne sais pas c'est
une manière d'entrer en communication
avec les autres je pense donc c'est
intéressant à voir
sa plaque d'accord ou pas d'accord les
nouvelles plaques entrera en circulation
au 1er janvier 2009 pour toutes les
voitures neuves
mais pour garder quand même votre plaque
ancienne génération il reste bien une
solution
si vous ne changez pas de véhicule rien
ne vous obligera à changer de plaque et
il sera encore question ce soir sur
france 2 de circulation et plus
particulièrement de sécurité routière
vous avez rendez vous avec béatrice
schönberg à partir de 20h50 et avec les
100 français qui font bouger la france
la politique faut-il parler de disgrâce
pour rachida dati elle était l'une des
proches parmi les proches de nicolas
sarkozy
aujourd'hui les difficultés s'accumulent
pour la garde des sceaux qui ne fait pas
partie par exemple du petit groupe de
ministres consulter régulièrement à
l'elysée
elle est mise en cause au sein même de
la majorité et nicolas sarkozy lui-même
est venu à son secours en conseil des
ministres pour tenter de faire taire les
critiques
alix bouilhaguet bruno vignais
réconforter rachida dati en plein
conseil des ministres nicolas sarkozy
vient de lui rendre hommage et lui voir
le monde
de quoi rassurer et pourtant dans
l'opinion publique son étoile commence à
pâlir
l'histoire commencé bien avec nicolas
sarkozy l'été de tous les voyages aux
premières loges états unis maroc fine
ici avec le fils du chef de l'état
la soutenant cécilia sarkozy pour
l'enterrement de jacques martin
aujourd'hui la presse s'interroge on dit
qu'elle serait moins influente à
l'elysée autoritaire dépensière ne
maîtrisant pas ses dossiers
les attaques fusent de toutes parts est
la cible de la majorité aussi vous
imaginez bien que quand on fait ce
qu'elle a fait la réforme de la justice
et la réforme des institutions la
justice
évidemment ça plaît pas à tout le monde
ça plaisait pas non plus aux députés de
la majorité dans la sphère la carte
judiciaire
la faille est mise en minorité par ses
propres amis a fait preuve d'une grande
violence et beaucoup de mépris à l'égard
des représentants de la nation
elle a déjà perdu une dizaine de ses
collaborateurs d'une veulent plus
travailler avec elle pour nicolas
sarkozy pas question de lâcher le
symbole de son gouvernement
dès ce matin il organisait la riposte
sim apparemment une petite campagne de
la début de campagne de lynchage métro
n'a aucun sens aucune des civilisations
le président a une occasion de saluer la
qualité de son travail au ministère de
la justice rachida dati qui doit tout à
nicolas sarkozy c'est aussi que son
avenir dépend exclusivement de lui
toujours à propos de politique les
parlementaires de gauche ont officialisé
aujourd'hui leur départ de la commission
copé sur la réforme de l'audiovisuel
public il estime que les arbitrages ont
déjà été rendus par l'elysée que les dés
sont pipés
de fait c'est toute l'économie de la
télévision publique comme privée qui est
en train d'être revue de nouvelles
mesures favorables à tf1 et m6 ont en
effet été annoncé daniel wolfromm
christophe vignal ce matin au sénat pour
sa réunion du mercredi c'était portes
closes à la commission copé et pour
cause six de ses membres tous
parlementaires de gauche venait de
démissionner entre deux couloirs donc le
président de cette commission avance une
explication purement politique
faut pas se cacher les choses il ya eu
une décision du bureau politique du ps
qui est
demander clairement aux députés
socialistes de ne plus d'une pluie
participer moi je regrette les
démissionnaires eux exposent leurs
décisions prises notamment après le
refus du président sarkozy d'augmenter
la redevance
on ne peut pas servir à partir de
maintenant de caution à quelque chose
qui habille on sert le privé on
affaiblit l'audiovisuel public
concert le privé allusion au fait que
tf1 et m6 serait les grands
bénéficiaires d'une deuxième coupure
publicitaire une manne de 300 millions
d'euros
même pour ceux qui restent dans la
commission ce projet du gouvernement
tombe mal son annonce a été
particulièrement malvenue dans le
calendrier après on peut débattre d'être
peau d'être contre c'est une autre
affaire ce qui est gênant c'est que les
mêlant les messages se soient mélangées
l'action de tf1 est en baisse cette
annonce inopinés l'a fait vite remonter
tout se passe comme si de grandes
manoeuvres avaient déjà commencé dans
tout le paysage audiovisuel français et
ce bien au-delà du cadre initial de la
commission copé financer un service
public de qualité sans publicité
jusqu'où ira le téléphone portable une
toute nouvelle application va entrer en
fonction en grande bretagne elle existe
déjà en scandinavie elle permet à partir
d'un mobile de localiser en temps réel
ses enfants ou ses amis
à condition qu'ils disposent même bien
sûr d'un téléphone et qu'ils aient donné
leur accord préalable à londres
explications maryse burgot laurent des
bois ils ont un peu des looks d'espions
c'est d'ailleurs une sorte de service
d'espionnage par téléphone qu'il propose
c'est un moyen simple et facile qui nous
permet de répondre à la question que
tout le monde se pose on fait les frais
y as où êtes vous vous êtes donc au pub
en train de lire le journal
vos amis peuvent vous localiser en temps
réel
la technologie utilisée est la même
que celles qui permettent aux policiers
de piste et des suspects moi je trouve
ce service formidable quand vous êtes en
vie par exemple vendredi soir pour
trouver très facilement vos amis c'est
excellent les gens commencent en avoir
assez d'être surveillés et ils ne
veulent pas forcément que tout le monde
sache toujours où ils sont assez
réticents les créateurs du concept
réplique que pour être espionnés il faut
l'avoir acceptée il faut d'ailleurs être
majeur pour souscrire un abonnement
le nouveau réseau s'appelle smith ils
permettent aussi de se rendre invisible
quand on le souhaite
le danger est évidemment d'oublier ce
clic magique
impossible par exemple si vous êtes
membre du réseau de prétendre que vous
êtes en reportage au pays de galles
alors qu'en fait vous êtes dans le
centre de londres
direction le cambodge maintenant avec
une cérémonie exceptionnelle en présence
du roi au coeur du temple de bayonne sur
le site d'encore une équipe
d'archéologues français à restaurer
reconstruit un énorme bouddha inauguré
aujourd'hui la france qui est engagée
depuis 13 ans sur ce chantier envoyés
spéciaux pascal golomer sylvain
guillaume ce serait une plongée dans
l'histoire
s'il n'y avait sous l'ombrelle les
costumes cravates
le roi sihamoni du cambodge est venu
présider aujourd'hui une cérémonie comme
le temple du bas à points
on n'avait pas connu depuis cinq siècles
une consécration religieuse pour honorer
une pièce maîtresse
un bouddha couché de 75 mètres de large
toute une façade reconstituer pierre par
pierre un bouddha dans le visage serein
ne se révèle que lorsque la lumière
s'adoucit le maître des lieux
c'est lui pascal royère cet architecte
est arrivé ici il ya 13 ans pour lancer
le plus gros chantier de restauration du
monde entièrement financé par la france
car ce n'est pas seulement le bouddha
mais tout le temple qu'il a fallu
reconstruire un temple bâti comme une
pyramide remplis de sable ses murs sont
insuffisamment épais comme ils sont
censés contenir un massif de sable avec
le temps le soin d'exercer des pressions
très importantes qui sont aggravées par
le fait que nous sommes dans un climat
de mousson lorsqu'il a aboutit très
rapidement dans l'histoire des
déversements et à des effondrements
celui ci en 1943 fut l'un des plus
spectaculaires
lorsque pascal et son équipe sont
arrivés sur place
voilà ce qu'ils ont trouvé trois cent
mille blocs de pierre étalé sur 10
hectares de forêt car l'équipe
d'archéologues français précédente avait
dans les années 60 démonter le tank pour
consolider sa base mais en 71
ils ont quitté le cambodge en guerre le
cambodge des khmers rouges et tous les
plants ont été détruits depuis 95
monsieur thiais se livre donc avec
beaucoup d'autres un gigantesque jeu de
puzzle en trois dimensions mon premier
sentiment en voyant toutes ces pierres
éparpillés c'était qu'on n'y arriverait
jamais et puis au fil du temps après des
années et des années de travail
je me rends compte qu'on va réussir à
restaurer 60 à 70% du temple d'origine
le bape one a retrouvé en partie sa
silhouette et ses bas-reliefs il est
surtout devenu beaucoup plus solide
les travaux devraient être achevés à la
fin de l'année prochaine tout près de là
reposant son tombeau le français jean
comai le premier en 1908 à avoir dégagé
le temple de la végétation
il avait prédit que sa restauration
serait un travail long et pénible
les caprices de la nature et de
l'histoire lyon donné mille fois raison
on en vient maintenant au tennis avec je
vous le disais en titre la belle
performance de gaël monfils vous l'avez
suivi en direct sur france 2 il devient
le premier français à atteindre les demi
finales à roland garros depuis sept ans
il a battu le numéro cinq mondial david
ferrer
et il sera avec nous dans un instant
d'abord les images du match nathanaël de
rincquesen chloé cormery c'est une vague
de bonheur qui déferle sur le court
central de roland garros gaël monfils
59e joueur mondial n'en finit plus de
surprendre
aujourd'hui c'est l'espagnol ferrer un
spécialiste de la terre battue
tête de série numéro 5 du tournoi qui a
cédé face aux coups de boutoir du
français dans la première manche monfils
frappe un grand coup et s'impose 6 jeux
à 3 en 40 minutes
les deux hommes commence alors un mano a
mano du fond du court
épuisant surtout pour mon fils qui
visitent le central dans le deuxième set
il perd du terrain et doit s'incliner 6
jeux à 3 l'espagnol semble avoir
retrouvé la maîtrise du match
pourtant dès le début de la troisième
manche c'est mon fils qui se détache
poussé par le public le français semble
en état de grâce
6 jeux à 3 dans le troisième set la
quatrième manche tourne à la correction
après un peu plus de deux heures d'un
match finalement presque à sens unique
monfils infligé un cinglant 6 1
l'espagnol ferrer il n'en revient pas il
n'est sans doute pas le seul
en tout cas mon fils a gagné le droit
d'affronter roger federer vendredi en
demi finale
voilà et comme prévu gaël monfils qui
est avec nous en duplex d'abord toutes
nos félicitations
vous n'avez pas l'air très euphorique à
quoi avez vous pensé juste après cette
balle de match victorieuse ramassamy son
premier
ma famille et surtout à tout le travail
que j'ai pu accomplir alors vous êtes
59e mondial vous avez battu le numéro
cinq mondial qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ces dernières semaines où ces derniers
jours pour arriver à une telle
performance est ce qu a eu un déclic je
pense mais surtout c'était par rapport à
une bonne préparation de confiance en
soi est une équipe vraiment soudée
autour de moi qui ont été la même dans
l'est dans les moments durs qui est qui
m'ont remis d'aplomb et je pense que
tout ça fait que je me sentais vraiment
bien sur le terrain est très heureux
donc j'ai pu produire un très beau
tennis
alors on vous êtes ça fait quelques
années que vous êtes sur le circuit mais
on vous connaît pas forcément très bien
ce que vous pouvez vous présenter en
quelques mots quels sont vos points
forts et quels sont vos points faibles
sur un court ah non je ne donne pas je
sois toujours en corse donc le donnera
la fin du temps dans adacore faut
attendre la fin du tournoi exactement
les points forts peut-être quand même un
multiservice à je préfère pas le gars
comme ça rejaillit soit rien du tout
alors vous dites rogers parce que en
demi finale c'est le numéro un mondial
rien que ça retire federer qui sera face
à vous comment vous aborder ce match et
ce que vous espérez gagner est ce que
vous pensez en avoir les moyens
je pense que quand je rentre sur un
terrain c'est pour gagner et pour
l'instant le match il encore loin j'ai
encore une bonne journée
encore une fois la récup ce soir et une
bonne journée demain d'entraînement et
je vais tout faire pour gagner ce match
c'est sûr parce que vous vivez quelque
chose de complètement inattendu
j'imagine
à moins que vous nous disiez que vous
vous prépariez à cette demi finale
je pense qu'on se prépare tout au long
de sa vie quoi et maintenant ils
arrivent maintenant donc comprendre
dans mon côté c'est sûr mais surtout
c'est s'est pas encore finie donc je
pense vraiment pas encore à me dire si
c'était attendu une inattendue je suis
dans le tournoi et je reste bien dedans
eh bien merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous et gaël monfils
on vous souhaite évidemment bonne chance
et ce sera à suivre
et bien après demain sur france
télévisions sur france 2 bien sûr en
direct merci à vous glacer ou commercy
voilà gaël monfils la tête sur les
épaules il était avec nous juste avant
le début de ce journal un mode football
petite victoire pour les français dans
leur dernier match de préparation en vue
de l'euro 1 0 hier soir face à la
colombie du signés ribéry sur penalty et
ribéry très en vue encore dans ce match
en bref c'est le réalisateur et écrivain
à frédéric mitterrand qui a été nommé
aujourd'hui directeur de la villa
médicis à rome avant de refermer ce
journal je vous en rappelle deux des
principaux titres à barack obama et le
vainqueur des primaires démocrates aux
états unis il a dépassé hier le nombre
nécessaire de délégués c'est la première
fois qu'un candidat noir postule pour la
maison blanche
et puis risques réels ou précaution le
sait pas encore vraiment la commission
européenne à bruxelles a déclenché le
système d'alert après un incident
survenu dans une centrale nucléaire en
slovénie il n'y a pas de danger pour la
population et l'environnement a indiqué
une porte parole de la présidence
slovène de l'union européenne à
bruxelles
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50
ils font bouger la france autour de
béatrice schönberg sur le thème donc de
la sécurité routière
à demain
l'info en continu
sur france 2 point fr